but they are right and we are live
welcome to the iron Lords podcast
episode number 67 it's another glorious
Sunday and we are back at the roundtable
on the Lord's Day I'm extremely excited
about our very special guest so we're
gonna get right into it
I wouldn't introduce you Lord who I
consider game design royalty in whom the
ILP had the pleasure to cross paths with
at this year's PAX East this Lord's
passion for gaming technical knowledge
and enthusiasm for his craft is evident
in everything he does and despite his
professional stature this Lord is one of
the most humble and down-to-earth
members of our entire gaming community
introducing the design director and
undead labs and the classic MPD winning
state of decay franchise the Lord who
always be a 49er fan at heart and the
obi-wan Kenobi of video game design
making his debut into the realm of the
Lord's my man Lord Richard fogey how're
you doing sir good morning good morning
over here good afternoon over there that
was a largest red carpet I've ever got
room so it's alright we show you the
proper respect here at the round table
you ready get busy have some fun with
these other topics let's do it
absolutely man and of course you know we
have the four horsemen of gaining those
usual suspects at the round table
my co-host with the Col most my brother
from another mother difficult game
Conqueror and the howl of the young wolf
my main Lord addict how are you doing
sir what's going on you guys and for
once Lord King was late not me
don't want them under the bus early wake
him up everybody no foggy got the
receipts - we had to wake him up
we have almost technical gaming lord
this little game will list with a single
player selfish experience and is also
sastra Thomas mr. offline profile
Illuminati and Lord patreon himself my
man Lord sovereign how you doing sir I'm
doing fantastic we're doing great great
to be here with you guys today yes after
dumbest especially today by watching I
was on Xbox Live or my what was the
profile or line that is the key Monica
no no I was on Xbox Live on my switch
play together campaign they survive
together they gotta see
I know it's let's see of Lord focus on
the telus we have the Incredible Hulk of
this the excess gamer oh the Lord of
combat sports who was a man of his
convictions demands nothing less than
that premium experience it is to get
money game up dammit
you up today you are so going down let
the man finish my intro beat a little
bit
Lord King how you doing sir I'm doing
fantastic I see addict is at his
business early and I love this I hope
addict I know midway through the show
that 5-hour energy that you we have to
check your blood absolute pleasure for
the Lords in the round you know saying
of course we have the game ninja himself
this shinobi Lord kognito spreading that
realness in the realm of the ILP not
telling you what you want to hear but
what you need to him so before we get
into what the Lords are playing this
week I want to start off with Lord fogey
his video game system history his career
and passion for video game design and
what eventually led him to undead labs
and creating that amazing MPD winning
state of decay to my franchise so low
for you let's start from the beginning
just one like a console and a video game
system basis I know what kind of the
first game systems you hadn't what kind
of got you in the gaming you know it's
kind of a long story I can ramble to
feel free to come out mr. Florez Joe
Smith I remember being at this party
with my dad and it was it was a you know
young in their 20s hanging out drinking
beers and and I was hanging out my dad
didn't really know what to do with me
and my brother and and the guy whose
house we were at had an Atari set him
hanging around somewhere and he was like
let me set these kids up and he hooked
it up and we were playing it and at the
end of the night for whatever reason he
just gave that to my dad I'm sorry to my
dad and when we went back to my mom's he
sent that with us so that was like my
first system was this old-school Atari
is probably 26
600 I just want to ask you which was
that that had some you know cartridges
in the old school you know single stick
single button and Soler's yes my brother
played the hell out of that is all is
all multiplayer for the most part right
like tank battle games and tennis and
whatnot and so we that he would get
bored of it and I would start playing by
myself with both sticks and trying to
make stuff happen after that after that
it was the NES and it was hot and I
don't remember where we got that one I
think my mom kind of managed to hook it
up after saving up for a while we were
asking her for it for a while and it
showed up like a Christmas or a birthday
or something and then that was my that
was my thing for many many years through
some hot summers downing in the bay area
while the Niners were winning Super Bowl
Bubble Bobble River City a contra you
know all the other classics and then
yeah it got when I was a teenager I was
up staying with my dad for a couple
weeks and you know at that point the old
8-bit action was was kind of running a
little low and I convinced him that we
needed an upgrade we got we got the
Super Nintendo like I told him I was
like you know there's a new one of these
things and I knew all the tricks to make
my Nintendo not behave properly big Oh
dad you know the new one doesn't have
were you doing the blowing the cartridge
trick to try to get them to work oh yeah
yeah but I would I knew how to make it
not work to and then I would say this
work when I finally wanted to actually
play the games but I knew how to make
the screens come up all bad knows like
the new one doesn't have these problems
dad all these great games I mean he
showed he showed up after work one day I
was hanging out he showed up after work
one day with like a stack of 20s in the
sand he's like let's go get that new
thing
Oh shadow Papa foggy hilarious if you
got like a defected way I got that but
let me ask you this question cuz
obviously a lot of the law and some of
us
Sega kids now anything there was nothing
about Sega enticed you always NES lon
that was your brain was that no you know
it was oh it was always a cash issue
right I hadn't golden if I could have
had both and when I had friends who had
both or who had Sega side of the thing I
was I was over at their house playing
those games oh no jamming or all fantasy
playing all those feelings those guys
and and being jealous about the
exclusives that they got that we didn't
get it you know I'm glad I ended up with
the hardware I did it was it was a good
fit for me and a lot of those old-school
JRPGs and action games really like i
said they they kind of they they mold
you a little bit like what your tastes
are so nice man as that's some good
history man so you go through the 16-bit
era and then um Did you touch the dota 2
bit error at all did you bypass that you
know what what happens we naturally no
basically at the point where the
PlayStation came out I was at the
beginning of my career in the industry
and when I started I started at it was
technically let's see I my first game
gig was at Time Warner interactive which
was it was in Milpitas where I grew up
and and it was at the old Atari
buildings like you would go out there
and they had this hedge that was that
was the old Atari symbol just kind of in
that and they kept it forever and it
said Atari underneath it and then the
company got bought by Midway and that
was when I went from being a to working
on this fighting game this arcade game
but one which one which fighting game
every day it was called
juco thread and tenth degree at various
points that never came out
never came if you go if you go to like
some of the classic arcade game shows
sometimes somebody will have gotten
their hands on the hardware to run that
thing but it's I wouldn't recommend it
lots of people learned in lots of good
lessons on that project but but nothing
the end result was not amazing but so I
was already kind of in the industry at
that point and I was doing okay on
making I'm making a little bit of
disposable income so all the money I had
went into video games so when the ps1
came out I was able to just kind of buy
one of those like I didn't have to
manipulate anybody it was okay
I'll make some sacrifices on food and
rent in order to get the hardware
respect that you gotta respect that ban
cake you got but at that point I started
pretty much bought most of the major
stuff like I don't have like a the
wonderswan or anything but just about
everything else about the real game with
like a hundred percent you'll just think
that that wonderswan that's very man did
in my heart because I still got it I got
my color and I got the classic I don't
think those were backlit at all - right
so I got my I got my Neo Geo pocket
color and I was like this is a backlit I
have to play it like in the exact
correct lighting I brought that for
Sonic and she's not fighting that Street
Fighter um the Fighting's fighting shoe
something like that but I got my Neo Geo
pocket so I got it in camo blue that's
the game in history as far as the
decisions and stuff now as far as like
you mentioned Atari and I just want to
get like as far as like what kind of led
into video game design
you know what describe that process so
like the moment that I realized that
that people make video games it was a
weird epiphany for me so like like you
said kind of in the 16-bit era love
JRPGs and I've been playing them but
like I didn't really think about it too
hard and then Final Fantasy 3/6 came out
and that was one where I had to be
manipulative and by hooking by cricket
because those cartridges were so
expensive expensive people don't realize
people complain about the cost of games
now and DLC and whatnot but like back
then if a game came out on a big ROM it
was like $90 just to buy the extra
memory that was in that cart right so I
had a I had a lie cheat steal basically
to get the 80 80 something dollars after
tax to get that game but I started
playing it right yeah and unlike a lot
of the games that I've been playing at
the time I had opening credits like a
movie yes so cinematic
yes scrolling through and and you see
these names and I'm like okay peep these
are the people that are working on this
game but it's all Japanese names like
all the way down cuz Squaresoft over in
Japan and then at the very end up comes
Ted Woolsey right who did the
translation I was like oh maybe that is
a way like I could maybe learn Japanese
and be able to work on these things and
translate these things and then I could
I would be working on video games but I
love that and that's not what ended up
happening but but that was kind of my
first insight into not only do people
make these games but they're like I
thought all games came from Japan at
that point okay that was my experience
all my Nintendo systems and write you a
JRPG on it makes sense it makes sense
right and when you get to the credits
you see a lot of Japanese names I was
like okay that's where games get made as
in Japan oh oh whatever I'm not gonna be
able to do that but then you know seeing
that American name in there seeing that
somebody does translations like oh yeah
somebody has to do some work so they
come out here and then because of where
I grew up in a little town called
Milpitas you know we were not far from a
town called Sunnyvale Capcom OH
Namco there were a lot of come
these game companies because we're Atari
came up that established a presence kind
of in that in that area so anyway missus
on email error yeah and so so Sunnyvale
golf land was getting you know all of
these test machines me and my friends
would go out there play a lot of
fighting games back in the day and the
Milpitas golf land would not get the
first-run stuff that Sunnyvale got we
would get the second pass usually round
two of hand-me-downs there's an Atari /
Time Warner interactive / Midway
whatever it ends up being called they
would test a lot of their games over at
the mill Peters golf land so if you guys
remember that old dinosaur fighting game
primal rage yes yes that would show up
there and and and we would play that and
a couple of my friends from high school
were really really good at fighting
games they would go out to Sunnyvale all
the time do that stuff and they got
themselves into QA and Atari okay
working on that stuff and and just my
network of friends we ended up with
quite a few people that were working
over there and I got an opportunity to
to get over there into their QA
department I got in there I started you
know talking with some folks that were
that were actually doing the development
on the games and then that weren't
really strong okay like there there are
games being made here there arcade like
I was working on arcade games a weird
thing to think about now
twenty-something years later but working
on arcade games is where I got my start
and so I was talking to people
programmers and and folks that were
working on this game and I'd done some
QA for their game specifically and then
Midway bought the company from Time
Warner and there was a huge set of
layoffs all like kind of changing of the
guard and somehow I kind of survived
through all of that crazy and it's kind
of survived it yeah and then the folks
that have been working on that fighting
game that I'd done QA for they cancelled
that game but they wanted to make a
fighting game okay and I had a lot of
kind of knowledge about how certain
mechanics work and they were impressed
by some of the technical detail that I
knew about like fighting games like
it's really simple stuff that a lot of
fighting game guys know way more about
to me but I was talking with them and I
was like oh no see you can do these
special moves not just when the button
goes down but when it comes up there are
you doing once this is crazy but but
because of my rapport with them I was I
kind of finagled that more manipulation
in design and turn on your project and
stuff and the producer on that project
told me you know I was pretty young at
that point I was like 18 19 years old he
was like long he you got to go to school
and I was like okay and so he said at
the time he said you should be a
programmer and I was like why should I
be a programmer he goes because they
make all the money sounds good to me
you and so I started studying well there
was some stuff through various various
points my career where there was some
like reimbursement but ya know I was
basically going to school full-time
working full time but when your new
twenties you teens in your twenties you
have that crazy energy right now and
yeah so I was I was able to do some
computer science as well as the the
full-time work and then from there kind
of just it just kind of kept steam
rollin right like and that snowballed
into a position at a startup company
because I had some friends who had moved
to that startup company and then that
led to eventually another company in
another company just kind of kept going
and I was like okay I guess I do this
know now a long along that line that
journey I was checking it checking out
the resume did oh yeah
our Santa Monica studio yep so I was
just curious um during that tenure like
what did you work on there we don't have
tremendous talent you know and also the
second part of that question as far as
obviously we know they have a fantastic
franchise out right now you know yeah I
was not a war
ya know our good friend and we bumped
into it at e3 Cory Balrog was there now
yeah did you ever cross paths with him
during your tenure as well yeah
absolutely Cory and I Wow
yeah we work together I'm got a warm one
two thousand three so it's like we're
talking we're talking a long time ago
now we work together on that getting the
combat systems all tightened and yeah
yeah so you know the startup company I
went to from there I went to Sony Santa
Monica from there and went to dipper
interactive which is up in Seattle
ArenaNet and then the crazy thing you
asked earlier about like what my path
was that led me to hunt at labs and the
interesting thing is the one of the one
of my goals as a designer is to make
sure I worked on as many different kinds
of things as I possibly done right away
versatility versatility never wanted to
be spent so specialized that I was
considered one type of designer like
your own combat designer you're only
racing you know tuning designer you're
only content designer and so I spread
out kind of that diversity that
versatility and when I got to the point
where we were making a state of decay in
the first one I remember having this
moment where I was like I've worked on
driving games shooting games I've worked
on some strategy stuff I worked on
combat stuff okay that's also I think
everything in my career has kind of led
me to this point where I can work on an
open-world game that really feels like
six games crammed all together mm-hmm
not that that's awesome intro since you
said that because why are you breaking
that down I'm seeing parts of your your
different very you know experiences in
stay to the game because I did you have
a mechanic there's the fighting
mechanics then you got the the base
building aspect you don't see like the
pieces of fogey as cool
Wow so Sarah mark so at any other arm
before move on to next part like any
other but you said God war yeah any
other kind of big games or just maybe
small again that you worked on that met
a lot of people might not know it's you
I mean so the Sony Santa Monica stuff I
worked on Connecticut which had a
rerelease not long ago and I don't I
don't necessarily recommend but you know
II say what you will about Connecticut
what that was like the engine that kind
of jump-started jak and daxter right and
then into got a war I'm not sure how
that I'm not sure what the path there is
but but it is definitely what what spun
us into God of War like a lot of the
Connecticut team and then we had another
project going on at the time that that
got cancelled because Grand Theft Auto 3
but but like that team then yeah just
steamrolled and oh the team that you
know today a lot of the same there are a
ton of people were there from
Connecticut and are still there now it's
crazy to go to war like when you guys
were developing that that did everyone
there no it was like a gym that you were
gonna do for 15 20 years well the
problem is still there I think there are
some people that they kind of knew I
knew as I was working on it I was like
this is this is there's no way this is
not gonna be a huge hit and this is
gonna be a big kind of franchise and
honestly like talking about you know my
desire for versatility I was like I I
don't want to do this necessarily you
smart because what I like about your
decision process is you didn't lock
yourself in genre like you you kept
trying different things so that they
couldn't egg you and that's actually
very small actually like that you did
that's pretty a pretty cool choice I'm
pretty locked in the state of decay at
this point it's a it's a very broad game
so there's a lot of different fun things
to work on
the Delware that's what's up a great
great history right there so then let's
let's get to the main event you know
obviously that all kind of must have led
you to that path of our you know design
director for undead lab so how did how
did you get to that direction and then
working on state decay so coming out of
zipper and working on the SOCOM stuff I
ended up at a company called ArenaNet
arena it works on Guild Wars know which
is MMO at that point I had worked on one
of the expansions that they had for
Guild Wars which smaller expansion
called I of the north and then they
wanted to spin up they wanted to spin up
some new stuff and so I was working on
some new skunkworks stuff that never
again never saw the light of day but
some of the best experiences and best
relationships can come from those things
right you learn a lot and so what
happened there is I ended up you know
working a lot more with some of the
folks that ended up undead labs and when
when the time came for that studio kind
of get rolling I was you know still in
contact with those folks and I knew what
they had going on they knew what you
know I was kind of good at and I went
over there not as a design director at
first I was lead designer yeah I was
lead designer I was working on mainly
again moment-to-moment systems combat
shooting driving and things like that
for the first game and then over the
course of that project the design
director at the time ended up leaving
and they wanted to see if I could kind
of step into his shoes and I didn't okay
job and so they still haven't gotten rid
of me as a sub so at that point you know
obviously you know for us as gamers when
state of decay came out you know was
kind of you know not not well-known you
know and it kind of just evolved into
this like cult classic I was like you
know like this thing that people loved
in our personal level just because um to
me it's like The Walking Dead simulator
you know it you know aspect of the base
building in communities and
relationships and stuff like that like
when you guys were during that Croatia
but did you guys think it would it
kind of the first one we're kind of
developing to what it would it became uh
you know we we had you know we had
ambition for it we knew what we wanted
to like big picture that the plan was
always like when we started it was a
bunch of folks that have worked on mmo's
right so a lot of the the business the
business plan the thing that we laid out
for folks that were potentially gonna be
working with us was like we want to use
this game as you want to make it a whole
game but we want to use it to experiment
with ideas to build towards something
bigger and that bigger thing had a like
a lot of MMO trappings you know and and
and people were excited about that but
they were also excited about not having
to invest right out of the gate in a
game that might take four or five years
to develop and you know how much money
all and mmo's are just massive to
develop and they take all the time tons
of money but they were like oh but you
want to do this smaller scale thing and
kind of figure things out
that sounds great you have a cohesive
game idea but it's still really
ambitious and and when we got kind of
hooked up with Microsoft
they were like great you know what we've
got this Xbox Live Arcade channel that
we have okay yeah right that's right
yeah so we were trying to cram this big
game into a really small space because
Xbox Live Arcade games have a lot of
restrictions on terms of like how big
they were like yet to get everything
into like two gigs yeah you guys had
that size limit oh that's right you're
crazy size limits you know but we got to
be part of you know the summer of arcade
promotion like I love that I love that
so much with the 360 was kind of at its
peak and they were doing acts summer of
arcade and all motional things and like
I loved it so much and so when we came
out as sort of what was that that would
have been 2013 is kind of the the
premiere title for that summer of arcade
and it was right before Xbox one was
going to be coming out it was really
exciting it was really exciting super
hype and that's cool twice now twice now
you've been the pre-med game on that
flagship system twice now you did it you
did
with the 360 in the sum of games and now
in the summertime I like having games
come out in the summertime yeah it was a
bit of a surprise to like you said like
we we we were trying to build something
special but we're a very small team 20 I
think I was like 24 26 people worked on
that first game to get it out the door
and you know we didn't have a lot of
like you said notoriety we weren't doing
a lot of of press or marketing certainly
not like this last time but we showed it
at PAX it was little grassroots kind of
a vibe people really dug it and when the
game came out and it shot up it did I
mean it was it surprised everybody
what was the like the code like when it
when he did actually
what was the you like the studio coach
like how it like everybody was pom like
what was the energy it was everybody was
pump we were also really tired right we
just finished that thing and gone
through the launch process and and man
it it that it's hazy those last few days
I just like I had a young daughter who
had just been born like a few months
prior and and we were wrapping up a game
so crunching a little bit and a lot of
folks were trying to you know make it as
polished as we possibly could but you
know we didn't have as much support as
we did on the second one and the second
one you know still massive game it's
hard to massive sandbox games it's hard
to account for all the bugs and it cases
they run into but take that on that
smaller team where we had one QA person
internally or maybe two and then some
some resources from Microsoft but
nowhere near what we got for to and we
had a lot of we had a lot of interesting
challenges trying to cover combat so I
think a lot of us when the game shipped
a lot of people were playing it now what
we saw was all the things that we wanted
to fix wow that's pretty cool
last question reference to your son dad
was just like for the uneducated right
for those who don't know about you know
game design like what's like kind of the
biggest misconception you think gamers
have and then like will give me like if
you can I noticed a lot of things you
probably deal with what maybe like a
like a day like a mini day in the life
floor for what is that what is it like
like
day to day you know okay I'll try - I'll
try to tackle those the one of the
bigger one of the bigger challenges to
kind of help people understand is that
things that sound like they might be
easier or if you know a little bit about
what's going on in a game engine you can
go look I just flipped this bit and flip
this bit and flip this bit it's done you
just you fix this problem that I have
this is very present in my mind right
now because we are trying to fix as many
problems with static a2 as we can um is
that there's there's a big process for
that and when you got a game with a lot
of moving parts sometimes you can't just
turn something off and turns it on
without it affecting a lot of other
things oh your game was on you're
supposed to fix that we're trying we're
really told the certification for Xbox
is like long - that's that's another you
know the the cycle that things have to
go through because we can't just say oh
it's fixed now and we should just push
this live we actually have to go through
QA again to make sure one that it's
actually fixed - that it didn't break a
bunch of other stuff and and then like
you said the certification process to
make sure that all the t's across all
the I's are dotted you have to stick
with that to make sure everything's on
the up-and-up and so you get these
things that are art can be simple fixes
but they have to go through months of
processing just to get out the door
we've got some stuff coming out and I
try to be really careful about talking
about what's in patches or making
promises to people because they're
getting those expectations of like oh
cool they're fixing this it's like we're
working on fixing as many things as we
can but I can't tell you when those
fixes might eventually show up that's
and and sometimes we have things that
like because of the complicated you know
nature in which things all fit together
sometimes we have things that we'd like
to fix but we can't because in order to
do that like we'd have to do months of
work in order and sometimes things that
sound simple or seem simple just aren't
wow I've been told because we asked we
had some under lives employees on a
planet Xbox and we asked them about was
there any kind of character
customization plans from the start that
that's actually really hard yeah
with the way we have things up set up it
is really hard to quick whoo quick
question for the in based on a chain to
throw and shopping happen to Chad he's
like one do all games release with bugs
and then he's out to Rodrigo Romero he's
like oh you think they could ever add
PvP in state so yeah I mean even if you
look back at the old classics that that
didn't have the luxury that we have now
being able to update you'll find
something you like watch the speedruns
there's do it the big speedrun thing is
starting up today right the Jerry yes
and and every time I watch those guys
playing stuff I'm like I remember
playing that game it was perfect and
they're like no look you can walk right
through this wall right I see a lot of
speed runners especially played
blood-borne that are getting on top of
buildings and then when they ask cuz
they ask the devs at that afterwards
like look we didn't think anyone would
go up and it's like how much time is
being spent to find him how many things
can you fix you're never going to be
able to get them all ever and now I'm
forgetting the second part of the
question that yeah the second part he
said PvP was I ever thought about that
we certainly thought about it but in the
context of static a to what we want to
be focused on was the the co-operative
aspects of the game what folks were
asking us for was like classic state of
decay experience but they wanted to add
people in and and and was it before
before we actually got the show rolling
we were talking about some stuff that
Lord addict found where you could kind
of troll other people like by doing
certain things I don't want these things
to propagate but those kind of
experiences cause people to hesitate
when they say hey do I want to get into
multiplayer do I want to invite people
into my game I'm like I don't want
people being worried in the context of
state decay to about somebody showing up
and like messing up their community when
you get into things like perma death and
yeah it's not like I could just like oh
well they hurt you a little bit but roll
it back you're fine everything's fine
you just
minutes not gonna lie it smooth that got
me and coat into his game and they were
acting dumb
and I had a juggernaut two pharaohs and
like 15 zombies around me and I was like
I was custard I was like if you get my
character Gale and this guy was setting
off firecrackers and I'm like bro then
we threw a firecracker in my base and
I'm like what's going on because both
entrances they just came rushing in from
both entrances us oh man I'm done for if
I die in my base I was like I gotta get
I gotta bring the 50 cow out though
delvis that's cool history man leaned
over the undead your own stuff like that
so if finish it up as far as that um
just as far as now back to you again oh
I always ask this question all our
guests yeah hardcore of the hardcore for
now and right high five video game by
five five it could be they can't can't
be top funny is Theta k12 two kids with
Eddie India top five video games or
franchises
well yeah it's gonna say if I could
cheat and use Monster Hunter for all
five top franchise all times Monster
Hunter mmm that spent a lot of time with
that one let's see so let's see Monster
Hunter
I like the persona games a lot a lot
right now for some kinda live three
those are those are like all-time
classics for me so that's two let's see
what else I got
I like JRPGs and I love playing stuff on
my 3ds so I'm really digging the Etrian
Odyssey series which is like well you
know what I kind of grew out of those I
hate to say in the leg
structure the combat systems and stuff
like that they're there they're classics
for me and I can go back to them and I
love watching people playing but when I
try to play them myself they're the
pacing is wrong so was it a good you
don't like the term base like what what
is it is it is it just you don't like
the newer direction that you like the
Oder direction better and you don't play
the newer ones or you know I like 15 a
lot but when I'm thinking about like old
school stuff and look like kind of how
they they resonate with me as classic
yeah but 15 was really cool I love that
I love the new direction that I liked
everything about 15 about everything
about 15 wait the video about the
problems so we got those we got those to
honor the soul series I love everybody
knows right it kind of obligated to at
this point if you're a game designer
called me oh my god here we go once you
found out that that that new game for
Xbox the multiplayer games coming you
realize that they said it is harder than
those other soul games you like and I'm
out my life I see those dreams no matter
what from software says they can keep
saying this is the hard they say that
about every game they make this is
harder the previous one like I was
really hard I still couldn't get that
werewolf out of the first did you really
like not even kid get killed by music
I'm done - just turn it on yeah
lying to you that game is still at the
first phase with me and I'm watching you
I'm like wow this guy is so good he done
made it so far look at the little zombie
heads and all this stuff to post seeding
things and I said I couldn't beat the
first monster and of the werewolf in the
beginning yeah well you know what
somebody didn't get that message to me
and I'm still trying to beat them I
think knio knio early on is harder than
blood-borne but I beat the expansion on
blood-borne I've been told that's the
hardest thing in that whole genre be
careful so we've got like I says we get
the star for the top again we had the
first three
maybe those it was a monster hunter
Maisano persona persona right Games
Odyssey which is these cartography JRPGs
you get on your DS they're so good okay
well and then I came in with the souls
series and then what do I have in five
there's a company called ill Winter
Games and they make two games that kind
of alternate between these two games I
really like them they're um it's called
dominions and conquest of Elysium and
they're basically dominions is like a
fan it's like a fantasy 4x game where
like the the number of different
variables and different permutations of
things that they have so you pick these
nations you pick a nation and you pick a
time period the time period dictates
what nations that are there and kind of
the state of magic in the world and
wings around and then you basically are
going around trying to conquer the map
right either defeat your enemies or kind
of out them via economy and there are
these Thrones that you can get that give
you ability man the game is insane deep
like I have to money that's a study to
be good at the game Wow
and this the stories that come from them
that's the you know it's a kind of
driving force behind a lot of my design
stuff is I want people to be able to to
play the games that I work on
and have unique experiences and be able
to tell stories about those experiences
to their friends draw them in and I feel
like I get a lot of the that stuff out
of the ill Winter Games both the minions
and conquest of Elysium they're there
soon and a platform for those and I
don't like the platform and those are PC
games and like basically if a few months
have gone by since the release of one of
their games I check and I see you like
our they're releasing something else cuz
it got a cadence it's like two guys in a
garage and Sweden I think something like
that or making these games they're so
good but they're really so that's where
the really weird from the mmm-hmm no
doubt man that and you look at the art
for this game and you'll be like no no
I'm not into this you have to look
beyond it look at that then come on they
keep the art really simple they're not
focused on on rendering the experience
they're trying to get as much of the the
richness of what's going on in the
simulation in the game kind of doesn't
come through in the art but if you once
you kind of see like what you can read
the matrix right once the guy you're
going like I I don't see the code
anymore I see this this is once you can
kind of see that all of these stories
unfold in those games it's just
unbelievable so me and the same guy that
I play monster hunter with religiously
before monster hunter world kind of
change that picture everybody plays
monster hunter now but back back in the
day when it was just on the debt back in
the day previous generation before world
where it was on just the DS like I did
we had to convince people play it he
convinced me to play it he's the same
guy I play the ill Winter Games with so
he's just it's like the experiences I
have with that guy you know there's some
experiences real quick dusting in a chat
he asked them if you like XCOM and all
the Warhammer series X comma I I love
the new stuff but I only dabble with it
so it's all my its own on my pile of
shame that I have the backlog and the
Warhammer stuff the digital stuff you
know it's been I haven't played any of
the more recent ones I played the most
recent stuff I played was the stuff that
was at rel
mm wooden where they have the dawn of
War series I played a bit of that but I
think that I think that they're probably
based on me talking about this other sim
stuff they probably wanted to see like
do I play the ones that are just come
out I'm going to remember the names of
it I haven't played those yet at all
okay curious tremendous history dear man
I've been talking about myself so what
yeah let's get into what the Lord's have
been playing this week so let's bring
back the UM what you've been playing
specifically this weekend you can't say
stay didn't came right so that's we
played the main game that's president in
my mind is what I was playing yesterday
I'm trying to think back earlier in the
week so I played a bunch of stuff this
week played a little stardew valley hey
I played played some stuff with my kids
and I can't remember what it is right
now but I try to play stuff McKidd
trying to get my daughter into games
right now
yeah but last night I started playing
Mario Tennis seriously okay
and I tell you what that game is
hardcore I'm not even kidding like you
know I think people probably have a
misconception the big oh it's one of the
Nintendo sports games out on you but
somebody described it as a fighting game
disguised as a sports game and I was
like say no more oh and then I was
playing through their adventure mode it
is hard core it is so difficult
like I recommend it if you maybe I don't
recommend it if you're worried I seen a
lot of it at e3 and they look somebody
look it definitely look like I had a
level of depth that I was unaware of
yeah it's deep and it is like the Dark
Souls of hard it's so hard I had a
friend over last night so I taking
credit for he would be the hard stuff
and I'll be like look what I did cool
games this week Lord addict what have
you been playing this week I've been
plays steady decay - I can't say that
you
yes I've been playing actually been
playing neo and I started playing
persona 5 yeah sorry uh
lorica basu I've been skipping all the
school stuff I don't care you know it's
actually it's actually a lot better than
I thought it was I still get annoyed by
the persona exaggerations every time
every time I hear that I'm like dude
it's not that serious yeah that's what
I'm probably gonna play more persona in
that uh today and I gotta finish neo man
like they said it's the same squid
that's in the oceans been killing me for
a week now I don't know what I'm doing
wrong I always had him dead he was
literally an inch of health away and I
was I was literally saying what I'm
gonna do but I didn't do what I said I
was gonna do did you get did you get
sloth yet have you gotten that power yet
sloth I don't think I have cuz I have no
clue what you're talking about
motion power it's a it's a power that
you can you hit them with it and it
slows them down I don't use any of those
abilities you know magic it's difficult
I'll use the super but that's all and
healing stuff that's it Wow like the
typical potions I don't use any of the
magic I don't catch my sword on fire I
would what what hardware are you playing
on the ps4 so you're like I don't use
the circle button expose it is it just a
circle it's not that restraint it's just
like I haven't really learned how to do
I was like
when I played these games I'm more about
like memorization of patterns they that
to stop them in a time vortex if they
can't get out home I mean that that's
why that game after a while can get a
little easy if you have the right powers
no it's off like you've been playing as
we move like I said I was playing on
xbox live on my show and like Lord folk
yeah is some state of decay - I'm trying
to get these plague hearts out of the
way because they're really not and do
once you like even the third clay cart
in an area gets really tough like they
start coming in from all doors if you
have like three four doors in a building
and some cracked windows like they're
coming in from everywhere everywhere so
I've been slowly working through that
trying to get some better weaponry and
and like lord fogey said like mario
tennis there's tough man like it's it's
not what people expected it what about
those no no no your context is right
right but certain times you do just will
be talking about something and we don't
have those three game we talk about you
always switching well you know what it's
amazing but I like your portable
this is the abuse we get from one out so
that's pretty much it without Lord King
would you be playing sweet
let me tell you something getting
acclimated back into society from being
depraved for it from video games all
weekend Callie is this is hard like give
my wheels around games and we were
videotaping games and we might having
we're doing all this stuff with games
but we didn't get a chance to actually
get into our little niche our little
things so getting back into it I got a
backlog of crazy stuff like I missed a
bunch of night falls and stuff that I
had to do shoutout to the trihard so my
boy Chris arm shout-out to the stream
team l-boogie and shout-out to the pub G
love so I'm trying to get back with my
team and get that flow back and I'm
doing pub G I'm doing state of decay too
because I know we'll be talking to folks
on Sunday so if I'm doing destiny and
the destiny love back for what they're
doing now is so tremendous is so creepy
yeah we're really out this relative
salty and everybody that's um yes down
with the clan join the clan and destiny
because we actually run raids and stuff
like that but I've been playing all week
trying to get acclimated back we got
that chicken dinner l-boogie nice oh it
was beautiful
um but yeah last night I'm playing with
Lord sinister and he's like y'all can
help you with your state of decay oh
let's do it right so they jump I said
how we get you into my world um that
whole bring people into your world is so
easy so you jump in and and thank you I
appreciate that Foley because this is
some games like Monster Hunter
you know what he knows what I'm talking
about cuz they still use it as homemade
is so easy to get people into the game
and the help out and it rewards that
they get when they leave your world
because I'm gonna chat with them and
they like yo thank you for helping me
out I'm like what the hell you talking
about using my worries and now I got a
yes so playing a game yo yeah I
understand the hook now I almost died by
myself yesterday I run in and I'm like
yeah I'm leaving that's the smart play a
lot of a lot of people do want to punch
through see see that those are the
people I call the people that are on
Twitter say stated case hard that you're
outnumbered
throw throw a cocktail and employee
leave one of the greatest skills in the
game is to call it the know when to fold
em I'm sorry get [ __ ] post III man you
guys have been working hard
yeah it's kind of like us Conant getting
acclimated from me it definitely been a
state of decay secret I'm kind of bare
said I had to I didn't know how to do
like guys have probably my leader cuz
I'm trying to have like to decide which
one I wanted to make and I wanted to go
to trader out and I was having a problem
you know assigning the leadership big
and act like no dude it's just right
there just but the guy on the floor
like that I'm not blaming anyone always
always good to get critique always good
to learn from people that are actually
playing the game like okay here's ways
we can make things better because the
map was yelling at me to do it and I was
like okay
and then now I put it off for a long
time like do I have to do these bishops
versus like no I'm like because I put it
off all because I really I knew I wanted
a trainer and I finally got this chick
from another community in my community
someone alright cool she's gonna be late
I can get that train of skill going and
I was stuck for it I don't do it I got
adequate music party chatter yeah cool
so I finally got that going we gonna
move over to another base on the other
side of town it's got some like like
almost like shipping crates or something
like that yes please since we got you in
your I do have a quick question real
quick now when you move a base did I
take all the resources from everything
that you built and break it down or does
it or you lose that give them back yeah
you get a read you get a refund I don't
know if it's a hundred percent but you
get a refund for a lot of the facilities
and stuff that you have built you get
all right I'm kind of figured that but
he asked me that I was like that can't
be a hundred percent yeah I got a lot of
stuff I got like six cars I'm sure I
literally have six cars if my
multiplayer all the other people from
their sessions are coming you'll get me
shout out to our monkey like he got me
cars and I have so many so I'm like how
do I do this yeah yeah I got two but I
got like MTV Cribs I was doing state of
decay this week on the shout till I came
destiny to iron banner in full swing
shout to everybody who's joined a little
podcast on me being ahead of you oh my
god that was that we gonna talk about
that we won't talk about that I didn't
appreciate that we go we go to me but of
yeah other than that
you know banner saga I want to switch
I'm really getting into it really
getting it down I think solve you need
to check it out and actually I'll check
it out it's a little different from XCOM
in a sense head of my exponents okay
yeah
art style is really cool and I like the
arm like I said it's all mo it plays
more like chest and it does excellent
because you move one character the AI
gets to move another character so it's
like the old Final Fantasy Tactics yes
in a sense but what's cool is like the
little art style animators for the first
game it's a pretty good looking for this
time style game and they have almost
like Mass Effect style story choices and
I'm assuming that I believe there's like
different endings and stuff like that so
it's a lot of different systems going on
really liked it that's what I've been
rocking so let's get in last week's poll
the results are in and the people have
spoken to the question when watching III
press conferences how much does a
company's presentation and format affect
your rating of said conference the
winner at a razor close 46% is yes bad
presentation of X conference rating I
saw see it was really high 41 percent is
no great games are greater than the
awful format and content shallow third
face at 13% but I don't care all the
lords who participated in the poll what
do the Lords think about this anybody
can jump what everybody felt after
watching certain companies press
conference you know when we know a
company is known for one thing and they
show up lame it actually is a double
effect you understand is because it's
turned back to us like what they didn't
put the effort in or on a Colston now
and it really turned it was like that's
what a crowd really turned on them and
now their new narrative of they're not
allowing people to play with other
people is it's starting to fall
and I'm hearing a low hum of oh this
company is a bad company and I'm like
wow they turned on them overnight and it
took one bad press conference no it was
weird presentation you feel does play a
factor how you feel about that floor
fogey about our conference presentation
I kinda have to abstain a little bit
from this but for me you know I love III
I love well I love it when I don't have
to go and present stuff eight hours a
day but like the the opportunity for
team who's you know a lot of these teams
been working on these games for you know
three four years kind of in secret
having to keep secrets it's such a great
weight to get off your chest to be able
to finally talk about the things that
you've been working on it's out there
people can see what you've been putting
your energy and effort into making art
is hard and I always love regardless of
like the perception of quality of the
presentation when I get to see a game
being shown to the world for the first
time or like getting those details I'm
so happy for the artists that have been
making these games for so long to
finally get that that out of them and to
see it in front of the world because
that's why we do these things we we make
these games so that people can love them
that people can play them and so I'm
always just really happy to see these
things and you know sometimes a trailer
doesn't land sometimes you know the
structure of a presentation might not
fit with with folks we're hoping for but
man it's just so nice to see all these
great games and to see people
celebrating these games that's that's
pretty interesting like I said we we had
that discussion last week and you know
about presentation and how people feel
about it now yeah I do agree with you
not folk about the end of the day you
know we are happy to see things for the
first time and just see that you know
that feeling of seeing something
presented and it looks awesome and you
know definitely shout out to the teams
and anyone that works on that so well
we're gonna have a new our people at the
end of the show so stay tuned so well
since we have the legendary Lord folk
you know around we're gonna switch it up
instead of the topic format we're gonna
bring back the ask your Lord Q&A segment
and pick the brain of the obi-wan itself
so I'm gonna set this thing off man so
obviously a huge announcement you know
at this year's e3
you know low fog infill kind of
unveiling undead labs as part of the
Microsoft studio family I call it like
fills and fitting gauntlet took over the
universe I was I'll be honest like man
we sold me person so happy to see that
that's named there so ah which was also
then reiterated by a studio head your
boy Jeff strain you know you guys made a
statement about focusing on taking the
state of decay franchise further and
contributing to build the world of state
of decay so first of like how long did
you know and then like how excited are
you you know about the future of on
their labs now I didn't know very long
before the announcement was made at e3
these things because you know they they
want that too they want that moment
right they don't want they don't want
any opportunities for folks to be like
oh yeah this happened and then it starts
to buzz out through the industry and
people got the rumor mill and all that
stuff so they want to make sure that
their that their timing is perfect with
letting folks know about what's going on
so that the announcement can have the
most impact so it wasn't it wasn't much
longer before that announcement which
was just great because it was driving me
crazy like you know I was like this is a
pretty big important secret that I have
to keep my hands on definitely but it
like did like my question now is in
reference to that same thing was like
now as a result like you don't people a
lot of people are speaking to they're
really excited about this you know the
franchise moving forward and what that
what that can mean and you know a lot of
people say hey you know now does that
mean you guys get to triple a treatment
or the other part I'm saying I'm also
saying it's like will this now effect
may be retroactive Lee to stay today to
maybe with DLC and stuff like that now
that Microsoft's kind of really invested
in you guys I mean that they've always
been really invested in in state of
decay too and making it the best game
possible it's been it's interesting like
a lot of people been talking publicly
about their their intent behind the
studio like you can go
check out so just jump on Google and
look for like Phil Spencer or Matt booty
interviews talking about you know the
the purchase of the studio and what
their intent is it's it's a wild place
to be in where you know I have to keep
quite as much I have to keep tons of
secrets right but I don't have to be as
coy as I have been in the past about
what it is that the company's intending
to do is we move forward it's clear you
know so that's really nice I'm super
excited about the future of the
franchise possibilities that open up our
relationship with Microsoft on the first
game was on the second game was so tight
like you saw that with the presence at
PAX yes huge presence great spot in
their booth they they loved the game and
then they did a fantastic job of
promoting it you know when you look at
things like the NPD stuff which is super
exciting thank you I don't think what
yosity what was like your emotion when
you got on you know Twitter and solder
or did you know before Twitter before no
no actually like that the the the report
came out and that started circulating
around the office like you got a slack
channel right and it was basically since
all that stuff came out and then it's
the tweet started showing up pretty much
at the same time so no I didn't know
about that ahead of time we knew about
it exactly when everybody else did it
maybe a little slow in my case um and
it's you know it's there's a nice bit of
validation there that are enjoying the
game they're getting out there and and
and buying it which is fantastic you
know MPD doesn't cover everything and so
we got a lot of folks that are enjoying
the game on game pass which is a
wonderful service like you get to check
these games out actually my cousin
bought he played it on game pass I don't
know why it does it but he'll play a
game on game pass and he'll just buy it
after it's like he uses it as like to
test all games because there's certain
things that you won't get out first of
all shut
up to you guys how you treated us at tax
night I must say it was first of all
from from getting in different email
gonna find this guy
and we had to show it when we got there
and Johnson to the back of the
restaurant a guy had the nice spread
when we met that dude he was like okay
now you go left and was like what left
he's like just keep going left we got in
there and you guys are super inviting
the hoodies from from the swag along you
know to the the love environment and I
know that your studio is really tight
because you guys Rock like yo shut up we
got to give some shoutouts to like shout
out the branch of the jet stream
shut up shout out my boy Lewis man Louis
D after yes I think yes yo he sho mad
love I know he had a part I believe on
the stage a level design I believe and
yeah he's a big destiny guy we were
talking gaming and stuff like that and
like you said King I mean undead labs
really really rolled out the red carpet
for us I love from you guys
after that shoes I got back to New York
and I got back on my xbox I'm always
getting the gaming game past but I
purchased the game straight out I said
because I want these guys to succeed as
much as possible Thank You Man
yeah I said because they were genuine
like after we talked wheels like oh we
follow you on twitter like literally
like right then I said you know these
guys are going above and beyond and
they're not doing it in a fake or phony
way they're doing it actually it wasn't
was it was genuine when y'all was taking
us on the screamy enjoy y'all had the
game right there playable and y'all was
going through little things with us like
you know this is the part where we
worked on this part and we sort of stuff
ahead of time
and you know reported on it and we just
came back from that part that was a
highlight for me for pax being it was
all first pack yeah I definitely didn't
get a plate on the floor because there
is like 50 people wait in line but yeah
I don't have time for that no Cognito
and King showed up their worst role in
and and hi this is one of my highlights
right I still remember that experience
we're hanging out talking about the game
kognito is playing and you're like was
that particular demo said to like a
higher difficulty because like I
remember that being way harder than I
play oh maybe it's because I wasn't used
to the guy must have been trash when I
played that impacts like getting tackled
by a but no we did so we did some stuff
because he scaled it up like a natural
ending to it so we had a lot of stuff
that was turned off actually so that we
weren't distracting to much from people
being able to go and do their thing
and then it's a ten minute demo at
around seven minutes we turn on some
stuff oh yeah we had a lot of people
have a really good it was it was all
deliberate but we wanted to make sure
that people can have those either a
really good super hero moment at the end
where they take that juggernaut out or a
really good story walking away about
getting torn apart definitely appreciate
or you can always just go in the house
cuz the junk and I can't go in there
with dad
play smart euro no you should see that
me you who was a sinister we had we
literally kept hating the juggernaut of
a car only see what was the headlights
wrong and we hardly just kept circling
him and he giving him one at a time with
the car that the party that post packs
party was so fun our communications
director Wonder rustles she she put that
together working with Microsoft to kind
of talk and getting back to talking
about Microsoft support and the
marketing and PR for this thing I would
I was all over the world in in Martin
March and April right March kick it off
with packs seeing you guys hanging out
showing the world the game first
gameplay and then after that I had a
week off and then I was in you know I
was in San Francisco I was in London I
was in yeah I was everywhere showing
people this game and they supported us a
hundred percent they are so behind this
game they're so behind this franchise
you guys so the the the outlook is very
bright my confidence in what we're going
to be able to put together moving
forward is very high they're great
partners to work with and now they're
not just our partners like we are a part
of what they've got features bright yes
so with that said like do you guys I
know you guys gonna be working on DLC
and wouldn't office stated k2 but do you
guys have an idea already is it white
board it's somewhere like what it's it's
too early I got I got I got some
twinkles in my so besides that though
the fact that you guys are now a
Microsoft studio is there also
possibility that you guys can split off
into two teams have two things going at
the same time or is everyone just
focused on state of the case
everybody's super focused on say okay
you know who knows what the future holds
in terms of
of what we would do but but right now
all of our energy and all of our times
be put into like I said the dlc dlc is a
highest priority right now getting
getting fixes and new fun content in the
state of k2 for players to enjoy and
then you know like I said people have
people that you go and look at these
interviews people spelled out what they
think is going on with us what our
priorities are gonna be and I'm excited
about embracing those priorities and
running forward hard let me ask you let
me ask you about one question reference
to that - I gotta be honest no [ __ ]
around with a low here comes it comes
yes now I must admit no dedicated
service for stating decay - broke my
heart I got really chewed and you know
there's been patches I know they've been
improved connectivity you know saying
but I have to know like what was the
decision process behind peer-to-peer I
know you know as far as like could that
change in a new future also because of
the acquisition like break that whole
process down from you so when you're
when you're making any game with any
kind of multiplayer in it at all you
know one of the big things that you have
to figure out is what your model what
your network model is gonna look like
right and network model can affect
almost the entirety of the game right
moment to moment gameplay the number of
players that you can get in and support
like distances and things like that that
we've had to deal with with like
tethering systems and whatnot if you
have a really big streaming world and as
we were breaking down the experience and
we were looking at the audience because
it's a big part of what you need to do
when you're when you're in early stages
of ideation and what what is this game
gonna be you think a lot about the
audience who are you making this game
for and a lot of a lot of our early
direction led us to wanting to make the
game that people were asking us for was
you know state of decay that I can play
with my friends but we also knew from
previous experience that a lot of people
are still really focused when you make a
game like this and you have kind of a
split between single-player and
multiplayer a lot of people are really
focused on that single player a lot of
people play this game by themselves we
can look at our our stats and stuff
Mangan mothership something numbers did
not dictate that way
well they don't dictate but but they
definitely give you information right
and so knowing that a lot of people are
gonna play this game the single-player
fashion because of the way we knew
structurally we want to stay focused on
a co-op experience but also a state of
decay experience where you have control
over your community you don't have to
worry about somebody coming in building
building something next door that you
don't like we weren't kind of looking
for that experience out of the gate and
once we did that the the server question
kind of pushes in in a particular
direction having hosted dedicated
servers cost money having having having
a drain having anything that that costs
ongoing money throughout the project
means you have to you have to be very
careful about how your game how your
business is making money cuz you gotta
offset some of that stuff so a lot of
what we talkin about at the beginning of
the project was you do we want to do the
things that that would be required to
kind of maintain these servers
especially if the game blows up big your
cost scale and then as those things grow
so because of where we were at we
decided that the experience we want to
have the the moment-to-moment stuff that
we wanted to do for gameplay how we
wanted that to feel our emphasis was
going to be on on prioritizing that that
that side of the equation and that led
us that the pure host and multiplayer
it's a it's a complicated thing right
there's a calculation putting on lots of
different variables to get me again
guess again attic and I follow up what I
was getting from that is like you'd
neither you had a couple different
directions of I assume that when it
comes to like I obviously I'm not in
that industry at all I have no clue how
that works
it would probably like it would go out
of the budget like for however long you
wouldn't want to keep those dedicated
servers and that would just be siphoned
off immediately somebody's got to pay
for that yeah so you wanted to take that
that money to either do that or put it
on the actual game and that's what yours
no it's less about like where the funds
would have gone kind of in the moment
and and what kind of happens after you
release into the wild right like they're
they're the reasons a lot of the
dedicated dedicated server games have
ongoing monetization systems that people
necessarily like we have to figure out
how to balance those things against each
other you've got some going costs you've
got to have something that gives you
ongoing income and there are a lot of
different ways to approach that problem
but you got to balance it out otherwise
you can make a successful game it
actually loses money that's real because
you know if the cost of buying the game
and somebody's you know over the course
of them playing it and enjoying it you
come to negative dollars an amazing game
I'm not having a sequel because of it
right well you can wreck companies that
way and again pre pre Microsoft
acquisition that's something that as an
independent student has incredibly
mindful about what what does our
business look like if if this is hugely
successful what happens if this fails
what happens you have to kind of account
for all those different situations
calculus with lots of different
variables and then you not like taking
the consideration is that I mean
obviously dedicated service is a big
thing in the industry now but that move
worth potentially hundreds and hundreds
of jobs so I knew I wanted I want to
double down on the whole thing I asked
again and I'm glad you're saying this
because it's kind of educating me on the
process see I was under the impression
that you know my money Xbox wouldn't
drop that you know all games but our
first part I guess we're going to have
you know dedicated servers so I was very
surprised by that I that that it wasn't
part of it but based on what you're
saying you know small Studios like that
that cost kind of incurred on yourself
as opposed to Microsoft kind of
providing this service for you guys
quote-unquote free of charge
nothing nothing's ever free right I
didn't know that
but let me ask friends is first up the
second part is like the follow-up is
there now
with the acquisition in the future you
know does this kind of levy $0.08 cost
no yeah I mean well what I could say is
the landscape is entirely changed some
light savers of the game ah I don't know
that we could negotiate that when when I
did the interview with a ninja Terry
Hayden Nina Curtis and um she explained
that him name-dropping right haha that's
right she she explained that the fear of
working in a small studio with the
thought of perma death for the studio if
you mess up with this game was very real
and I wanted to know did you guys
experience that was that your like
because you explaining that you had to
balance things back and forth and making
sure that this is profitable as well as
a good game um and it goes into the
thought process did was it on any point
that you guys were in fear of that and
once the acquisition happen the the
security that comes with that
acquisition there's there's a lot of
exhaling going around and at office I'm
pretty sure yeah you know the reality of
any industry I think but but I I know
most from games is that you know even
with the big successful studio something
can go wrong they could have layoffs
anything you know there's always you
have to always be mindful and thoughtful
about what your prospects are in terms
of ongoing employment taking care of
yourself taking care of your family and
whatnot but it as an independent
developer you know that's making games
and and your success is tied
to the success of the art that you're
putting out in front of the world it it
is stressful
I had a lot of confidence I wasn't I was
never really fearful about it personally
if like what would potentially happen I
had a lot of confidence in the game a
lot of faith in our relationship with
Microsoft but there were definitely
there definitely times when I would sit
down with some folks to have
conversations and they would say you
know
what do you think things are gonna be
like I'm a little worried about what the
future looks like do you think this
company is gonna be around in X years
when we're in kind of the mineral
development and you know as you get
closer to the end of the the project
cycle you're able to look at look this
game is great it's sure it's got
problems but it is fantastic people are
gonna love it
we've got marketing and support from PR
and marketing from Microsoft behind us
and like this game is going to go out
and it's going to be successful you
don't have to worry whether or not the
studio is gonna be around in like six
months
but but there are people that you know
like I said you got to be mindful of
that you got to be protecting yourself
certainly when the acquisition went
through and people are like is the
company still gonna be around in six
months I'm like I'm pretty sure they're
not coming let's buy you and get rid of
you so I do have a question when it
comes to the accusation entirely like we
obviously found out on Sunday I was told
you guys found out on Friday is that did
you know because you're a little bit
higher it on the totally change oh yeah
I'm way up the chain I knew on Thursday
they want to keep that really really
tight this was the best press conference
as far as that was going because when we
see a company that we are invested in
emotionally with the guys you know you
guys um and we see that happen like I
cheered for that like
like yeah Microsoft is committing to
their own and that was the vibe I felt
and I just felt like I just needed that
bump that financial bump just you know
I'm saying give you that triple a polish
and those dirty over and you know
they're like I just see because like you
said King is just a great group people
they work hard the game is good it's a
cult classic people love it you add it
co-op and it just excites me first an
indicator I'm so excited to see that you
got playing going on games the only game
I know of right now that people want a
better ROI well with anything because
there's so many of it will I stand in
case the only game around here people
allegedly here people like I want a
battle royale on this guy we got that
part I'm still having fun with my zombie
simulator that I'm playing that's what I
call it zombie crisis management they
say any plans for 34 frames per second
cap on an ability to disable motion blur
like I said earlier I can't really get
the word that we may or may not be doing
for future releases okay so I can't get
into it but we are we're listening all
the time and we hear you loud and clear
one last thing on the acquisition of do
you guys get the impression that you
know they you guys have said um and
ninja Terry said also that you know you
guys you guys are going to just do you
what you guys want to do and they're
behind you 100%
but do you get the impression that if
you come to them with like an idea for a
triple-a you know 200 plus our game like
huge vast game that they're fine with
that any of the the new studio is coming
to them with that or do they sort of
want you do they see like compulsion as
this
more studio game and you guys is like
the the middle size you know or do you
guys get the impression you can make
absolutely whatever you want whatever
scope whatever size it doesn't matter
it's it's it's interesting it's still
kind of early days in terms of what
that's going to shape up like I get the
impression that I'm going to be working
on state ok for the foreseeable future
but I think you know my my personal in
this again this is my opinion based on
my analysis looking at the conference of
stuff again Microsoft swinging for the
fences there they're not gonna stand
around they really they really want to
be on top and they be on top with the
best games the best hardware you know
and and making people happy so I I don't
know I don't know what that would be
like if I went to them with an idea that
I thought was you know worth a billion
dollars and said like here it is this
much money I don't know how they
responded that out of the gate but I do
know they're not messing around
know the human element man I gotta ask
you now what what about the initial
reviews obviously didn't Metacritic came
out being a little mixed you know how
does it really affect you guys
personally do you feel like it was too
harsh or do you feel like any criticism
was warranted gonna release some stated
Kay - um like I mentioned earlier we're
talking about network model stuff you
know you make a game for a particular
audience and it's interesting because so
much about this game is very similar to
a lot of stuff that we had in the first
game but we kind of try to make it make
it way better though one of the bigger
differences that we have between the
first game in this game is the number of
people paying attention and I feel like
if the first game had had this amount of
marketing impression and people coming
out of the gate you know we would have
seen very similar results there right
like it's it's a mixed thing it's not
for everybody some people get in there
and they're expecting a different kind
of experience you know you kind of have
to engage the game in in multiple
dimensions you have to deal with your
community stuff is not just an action
game people that show up just looking
for like a hardcore action game they
wanted the combat to be
the end-all-be-all we couldn't we didn't
do that right we had to we had to take
that complexity and way to spread it out
across all these differences we made
something that was really broad our goal
was to make a zombie apocalypse
simulation right and for us that meant a
lot of things and you know we'll get
folks that that I remember one of the
people in particular on the PR Tori's
playing the game is like I don't like
the night time is stressing me out why
did you guys put in something
it lets me fast forward through the
night time so that I in the daytime
again I was like well you know that
that's a thing that we could have done
but like our goal was to capture this
feeling this particular this particular
thing and people that are in this
situation wouldn't be able to fast
forward through the night they could
probably barely even sleep at night as
it is I had a friend that that said it
was too dark I was like it's night I've
made a pitch black yep I love that I
love that yeah that was a battle that
was a huge bang oh yeah man like you
know there are a lot of folks that that
you know you get used to what you're
used to right and a lot of video games
the night time is is like it's blue and
maybe you see quite as far but it's it's
not like they don't want to impede when
we were talking about like how close we
want it we want this to feel like a
survival game we want this context of
the apocalypse well man nobody's running
those power stations the lights are
gonna go out what is it like when you're
out in the middle of nowhere there's no
light
it's so dark and so you're just getting
light from the moon and the stars and
whatnot but that was a it was a huge
battle and our the art director for the
project Doug Williams clearly you want I
think it worked out right making the
game for a particular audience you know
you guys played Dragon's Dogma Oh watch
them play that yeah yeah that was a huge
inspiration to me like I played that
game and I'm like oh my god
it is dark I'm scared of being outside
I'm straight-up it puts a real like that
Catarina state like you know what it's
scared it's primal yeah
another game that does that is final
fantasy 15 like you don't go out in the
dark for a couple like 10 hours in the
game you don't go out in the dark yeah
and and so I like even at that point
talking with that that fella about like
his perspective and how he wanted you
know something particular I was like
this is gonna it's gonna be hard for
some people that they're not getting
exactly what they want out of it yeah
and but you know I'm not necessarily
here to create something that that
caters to everybody I'm trying to I'm
trying to please a particular audience
and if you look at the reviews they are
really sweetie like some cool that
that's a person for whom we made this
game and somebody else will give it a
little score and then I'm like okay we
we we missed for that for that person
how do you guys how do you guys handle
feature creep for for like a for a title
like this with so many systems on top of
each other like where do you put the
hard stop like no we can't do this in
this particular game I'm the king of
feature creep you get near the end of
the project and or even think I need to
come out we need to stop exactly we
can't just keep making the game forever
right nobody want nobody everybody wants
to make something the people eventually
play and keep added stuff indefinitely
nobody's gonna get to play it but us and
that's not fun and so when that reality
sets in what we try to do with the lab
is we try to keep looking at scope as we
go through the project and sometimes it
hurts sometimes it hurts real bad to
look at that feature on the wall you
know that like so many people are gonna
love that thing but it's got to go it's
got to go so that we can get this thing
out the door was there any particular
like features and stuff that was kind of
implied into the game but was took out
we you know we had some of the stuff
from and then this never it never got
past the point like where we're actually
doing any implementation on it but you
remember the journal from the FIR
yeah yes a journal that kind of had some
of the background stuff that was
something that I really wanted to have
in there in some form and but have it be
more valuable than it was last time
because last time there's some really
cool stuff at the beginning but after a
while it just kind of became this
dumping ground for all the spam for like
what happened with your supplies and
resources and for the most part players
were able to focus on that and people
would just weren't using it but there
was some really cool like storytelling
and reminders and things I think that we
could have built into that that would
have been fun but but ultimately when we
looked at it's like know it if I have to
have to take that over this other
feature say like getting the plague
hearts system working correctly right
one is fundamental to the game one is
gonna affect everybody's experience and
the other is something that you know
some people would have liked but you got
to play the percentages a little bit
because Brett actually told us some that
there used to be like a Jeep or a car
that was in the game for the longest
times that you would stress the server's
with it and it was like really fast and
you guys took it out like the very last
bit before the game actually launched
yeah we had we had we have there are
things like people or people are finding
stuff by cheating there saves in a
little bit little like this thing I have
and I'm like oh that's not supposed to
be rip that stuff all the way just take
it out of the game people know they
education let's go rip it up you can't
you can't leave that anything laying
around anymore people will go through
your trash one of my last questions as
far as the UM one thing I love about the
state of cage like the reward system for
kind of helping my friends right and
then like being able to bring you know
that rewards and influence back you
don't say so I just want to know like in
reference to the coop though like what
what a lot of people I know I don't have
a problem with I know when I first came
I always tethering know like you know
like what was the design process because
when the game actually release and shout
out to Jess quoting from Windows Central
and I got a chance to talk with him as
well
I felt the tethering bubble was way
bigger and it was like a little
overblown than actually stated so but
just give me the thought process
design choice to say okay we're not
gonna let people just run wild and go
every day one thousand directions on a
point of your map the the restriction
was I mean it's mainly technical right
the the the design didn't necessarily
call for any kind of constraint there
gotcha
um it was basically because of the the
level of simulation we're doing because
of the size of the world the number of
things that are going on in it you may
be have heard this before but we only in
this big world we're only really
simulating actively the area around the
host that is a certain size right that
works fine when you're single-player
because it's always just this bubble
around you that moves constantly and we
tried a lot of things to try to make it
work so that people can just go wherever
they wanted but we weren't able to make
it so like this bubble could just split
off and we'd have little things kind of
going off everywhere so because we
weren't able to make it work we tried
you know we we put in a system in place
that allowed players to get what felt
like a reasonable distance without
breaking game right and then just like I
said you could
there are various points where you could
outrun the streaming and before that
tether came in you would be running you
you know you don't know care where the
host is or whatever you'd be running in
or driving and suddenly you just fall
through the world because the arts there
but nothing else again and you are the
master of game design you are the jetty
the Jedi do we want like it's definitely
you know like you say like it's the the
world's being created around you for a
single-player I get it like exactly what
you're saying all right so just like is
it one of those things is that a CPU
constraint because it's so much to have
them people goals way far what was like
what's the constraint so to speak is it
it is a combination of like what's going
on power under the hood and
and memory so what all can you keep in
your head at once so yeah again I can't
really talk about with those code names
scarlet oh my god my scarlet I got it
King I'm sorry no no I'm just saying
that that that stuff I understand why
he's explaining in that cat in that
manner because he said it's a little
bubble now if you want to split that
bubble per person then you're gonna tear
up resources by going out let me do the
sound computing yeah could you imagine
if you're driving in a car and a false -
what do you know so I don't have a
problem with the tethering actually
honestly I never wanted to be that far
away from our friends in that game
anyway because I'm terrified I'm I see
the zombies in the street I'm like I
can't go a few feet without kids who's
screaming that he's about to get killed
like I can't imagine what it's like to
be on the other side of the mat there's
a juggernaut here I'm like dude I'm like
forever away but like you gotta really
think about it mentally if that world
really existed you wouldn't be too far
away from your friend no you're gonna be
so close to that person like technically
I'm gonna be sure to show to a kognito
that's he's a big dude gotta get cleaned
up I don't want the trouble no no I'm
staying close to everybody I think it
fits because because exactly what you're
saying like in the real
you would want to be close by but like
there's an emotional response people
have not necessarily based on the
reality because people were responding
to this before they played it it's an
emotional response they want they want
freedom they want they want to know like
I could do whatever
and anytime you put something in there
where the it kind of constrains the
experience that they're hoping to have
it will definitely get you know it will
get an emotional response family
sometimes when you actually play the
game doesn't it doesn't work out that
way but whatever like it you can't
control people's emotional response of
course they're gonna you're gonna feel
something whenever you hear anything
people work or / then I was like I'm
gonna shut you up one tweet it was just
and far cried you were loving that and
what I like too is that I want to give
you guys credit is that what I like
about the coop aspect is how you guys
separated the loop because I was gonna
be like if I go we go loop together and
someone hits the house first and it's
just getting all the resources leaving
my world it was I really because I love
having like you guys have the
color-coded separated per house so it
kind of prevents the grieving is to
prevent people from being greedy you
know to be I really like that design
choice yeah we wanted nothing to get in
the way of you feeling like you wanted
people to come in anything that made it
feel like they would be a negative
presence in your world want to get rid
of that and I do understand that because
we are in the gaming industry would
believe that this is the most trolli
industry in the world it gets up there
right
imagine Dead Island like how many
probably went on in that like I know
this because I was part of that troll
Lissa I know we gotta get funky idea but
how we getting close
who's gonna so any last questions for
the Lords before we move this thing on
get them out here soon everybody's good
I guess I did yes I mean no no no
actually I guess all the stuff that I
was talking about is really just high
praise to be honest with you because to
actually sit down with the game with the
corner by myself and to actually touch
on my leisure I've walked away I've
really tended not to listen to the crowd
I tend to go off on my own experiences
with stuff and I want to find out stuff
on my own I guess this is the gamer I
don't live vicariously through others I
live my own life
so when playing it I'm like wow right
it's like when I'm in the house and I'm
going through stuff I don't want to go
through the fast shuffle I want to take
my time and dig do to get everything out
so I may not play at the speed of others
like a dick is a dick is a serious dude
my speed works for me and I'm glad that
Chuck gave that whole option like night
time I was really terrified at me really
I'm like one question form real quick
and now I got Sam and then will allow to
be a lot of questions what's your
favorite monster and monster own my
favorite monster Monster Hunter Ratheon
well just a just a classic I love you
know every time I finally get to the
point any one of the games where I get
to fight with Rafi and I feel like it's
like comfort food
final question we're gonna leave it with
Lord same tow burner of TRC game Network
that come on told you said he totally
understand if Mitch can't talk about
this but does undead labs have any plans
to grow in size now that they are part
of Microsoft Studios we it's so early
that I there's nothing really concrete
there you know enough it's hard to it's
hard to imagine us shrinking it also so
okay how many guys right now we're a
little over 60
she expects we can do the poll that I'll
chose we can get fogey out of here and
yes so the call poll question will be
with the recent acquisition of the five
gaming studios underneath the Microsoft
Studios umbrella-like undead labs Ninja
Theory etc is it too early to tell if
these accusations acquisitions were
smart business move hey yes early proof
first be no not too early
these are smart acquisitions for the
future of X my wait for that seed let's
see I don't care until completes the
gaming studio Infinity Gauntlet makes
video card Infinity Gauntlet which I
think there would be some kind of
copyright things Lord fogey an absolute
pleasure to have you in the room ever
clap with King that's what we call
godless like that godless studio I like
that look [ __ ] absolute pleasure man
we're so proud of you guys
winning MPD indicate looking bright
where can the fine people find you and
what else you got going on you want to
tell our people honestly a tweet
sometimes rarely make us a 2k stuff as
we continue to go and make announcements
on DLC and whatnot
you'll continue to see stuff coming out
from us Microsoft and wait man hold it
hope is a steady stream of content well
I can't wait to see what you guys can
afford we getting Microsoft family DLC a
warthog maybe or
people say people yeah i gotta get up
i'm tired of halo gears 1/4 of the same
i'm just gonna get on the absolute honor
for you to come to the ILP routing
that's so much fun thank you thank you
so much let's get these out shows going
on Lord addict wicked to find people
find you what you got cooking it oh you
can find me on Twitter and it didn't
work out but actually I try to copy Lord
Jack Lou but we will know you know I
definitely appreciate a Lord Loki for
coming on here was a definitely great
pleasure to have you on the show I'm I
think I'm the only one here that has put
the amount of hours in your game oh
there we go
[Music]
you know I just made a video how to fix
fable for so go check that out probably
gonna make I was gonna make one um on
Final Fantasy 15 but people keep leaving
they won't leave me alone about why I
don't like fallout 4 so guess what do
you want making next it's gonna be how
to fix fallout 4 oh no so you know
definitely catch that when that comes
out
preciate everyone for coming on here
even even lower keen we have a guest in
line so you'll see that later on this
week absolutely but no it's soft
what's going on we're gonna find people
find you your farm yet Lord saw IOP on
Twitter check out that yeah I'm the king
of it I'm with lower Foley I'm the
retweet master what else
check out that patreon guys
patreon.com on those podcast check us
out you want to support and what else
north fogey an absolute pleasure to have
you thank you i mean eyes gamers
sometimes all we talk about is what we
want what we want we want and we forget
about the humans behind the game and and
it's to have you on here and to talk so
frankly about the game in your
excitement about what's to come
it makes me happy to we're gonna pop you
a check this out I just got the music
for the intros and outro music for
combat talk with the king I'm looking
for animators to do the intros and
outros or I got a special little thing
that I want going on um Lord fogey I
must say being that you were actually
the first face that we had the first
welcoming face that we had ad packs
there your first person we spoke to when
we walk door you're on the floor show
you exactly how personable you are and
how real you are and your team is
because the team exudes that same energy
yet he does so I don't want y'all to
think that he's the only person know
through a his whole team
exuse that same beautiful energy and I
will never forget that night in Boston
with you guys you guys actually showed
me what that pax experiences and I'm
looking forward to next year because of
you guys and I'm happy for your success
and to one that MPD's wargame that were
held higher than your games that
Metacritic rated higher than your game
on shows that that love that you put in
a game resonates through the community
and no type of hate on a game because
it's on a certain system and hold that
back so I do applaud you guys for the
great work and absolutely
I tell people all the time feels like a
David and Goliath story for us because
about MPD's revenue there's a $30 Gator
you know and it's on a smaller install
base and you know it so I think I still
think it can't be you know overstated
how Mendes that accomplishment is for
them to win under life to win it for
that game for MPD I think is fantastic
and I'm really excited about the future
I'm sorry for yeah cut off just gonna
say you guys made quite an impression on
me at PAX I really enjoyed my time with
you and I'm looking forward to the the
content you guys continue to produce and
the the I like the way you guys are
approaching things it's really great
I like your a lot man coming from you
guys coming from the industry at the end
of day like it's all about games is a
human element to it yes we want to have
fun
you don't say we don't want to be
disrespectful we want to bring people
together and games is that common
through remember impacts you were trying
to do that speech floor folk you know
what are you developers was playing the
game absolute pleasure once again
[ __ ] in the building all just
wanna pay the bills right here before
you get out of here I make sure I would
obviously you guys like hit subscribe
I'll pee channel and all the network
shot up the Lord carboxyl he will get
the timestamp up later today and then
obviously we had flashpoint number 20
with eat boxes that was on the ILP you
too
check that out destinies want to come
back y'all you need to pay attention
stuff going on and then also please
check out the e3 fan fest Lord King has
a fantastic playlist up right now rolled
to e3 in fan fest with the king you know
said you get to check him out
you see those working with we go we got
tons more footage you know we're gonna
start trickling that stuff out great
interviews with devs big and small you
know we don't discriminate just for the
big games so we have a Lord King did a
fantastic job right now he has a ninja
theory um dev interview up right now and
also like I said you get behind the
scenes just from a fan perspective how
it is to go to e3 what it's like to be a
fan fest it's really cool please check
that out please support try to get that
on ton of exclusive coverage on to you
guys
also the patreon really helps with shout
out the loss off for that for taking
that on there's but wing you know we
really appreciate those who contribute
it means a lot everybody enjoy their
Sunday the Lord's got anything else to
say before we get out of here
alright guess not everybody enjoy we are
out I'm going thank